d'abord quelle est la composition et la
dangerosité de cette coulée de boue
appelez-la alors les l'art en fait ce
sont des mélanges de matériaux divers
donc vous avez à la fois des cendres
volcaniques en grand nombre des
matériaux terrigènes donc de la terre
des roches de dépenses un des pierres
ponces essentiellement le tout mélangé
avec de l'eau et ça donne un matériau en
fait extrêmement dense extrêmement lourd
et surtout qui a une capacité d'érosion
très très importante en fait c'est même
peine qu'a passé d'érosion le vrai
peuple ce n'est qu'à passer d'abrasion
c'est exactement si vous voulez les
larges ou le rôle d'un rabot qu'on
passerait si vous voulez sur du bois
donc à partir du moment où ils vont se
mettre en mouvement ils vont vraiment à
raser le sol c'est à dire qu'ils vont
emporter tout ce qu'il se trouve en face
d'eux il ne restera plus rien ne sera
jamais plus on est d'accord
est ce que on peut mesurer sa force son
intensité il existe des méthodes
permettant de mesurer leur intensité la
dengue dans le cas précis je ne sais pas
si ça a été fait mais une chose est sûre
c'est que les images sont très
impressionnantes et on voit bien que les
volumes qui ont été déplacés ont la
capacité de mobiliser si vous voulez des
des blocs énormes donc le pont en effet
si l'ancien pont était et est encore été
encore présent de toute façon il aurait
été submergées voire totalement emportée
est-ce qu'il ya des systèmes d' alerte
prévu alors il existe des systèmes
dallaire en fait ce sont des appareils
qui ressemble un peu à des sismographes
et qui sont un peu ce bon voilà adapté
pour les l'art alors je ne sais pas s'il
en existe des spécifiques pour les l'art
en martinique mais ça existe à travers
le monde ou alors il y a eu des larmes
meurtrier 1985 en colombie 23 mille
habitants enseveli sous une coulée de
boue de huit mètres de haut est ce que
ce sont des scénarios possibles en
martinique sans effrayer la population
alors ce sont des scénarios si vous
voulez il faut jamais rien écarter une
chose est sûre c'est qu'en colombie le
phénomène était un peu similaire à ce
qui s'est passé en 1902 c'est à dire que
c'était un jour de vote et on avait
interdit à la population de quitter les
lieux pour voter donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y a eu autant de morts
aujourd'hui on
quand même la possibilité d'évacuer les
populations et de les alerter
même si on voit que les populations ne
réagissent pas comme il faut plutôt
impassible c'est son trésor totalement
impassible et ça c'est particulièrement
nocifs
mais il faut que les populations
comprennent que c'est un phénomène
dangereux et que face à ce type de
phénomène de toute façon ne faut pas se
poser de questions quand les autorités
disaient on évacue quand bien même rien
ne se passe il faut y tient pour
l'instant on n'y est pas on n'y
absolument pas d'accord pour revenir aux
origines des fortes pluies on l'a dit
serait en cause
mais quel lien pourrait-il y avoir avec
le volcan en fait il n'y a pas de lien
direct avec le volcan c'est-à-dire qui
n'est pas une activité volcanique qui va
générer les l'art là c'est simplement un
effondrement un glissement de terrain
qui a qui a alimenté la rivière et ses
matériaux sont ensuite évacuées par la
rivière et donc c'est ce mélange de dos
et de matériaux particuliers des fins d
dégrossi etc qui génère donc cette mas
bourrust extrêmement abrasive
alors on l'a entendu c'est un phénomène
qui peut se reproduire même dans les
prochaines heures
c'est un phénomène qui peut se
reproduire et qui est à mon sens se
reproduira et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans l'est on va dire les 8 à
10 jours prochains il faut vraiment
rester très vigilants à l'écouté à la
fois des messages que délivreront les
autorités et surtout ne pas fréquenter
la rivière est ce que d'autres zones
proches peuvent être aussi concernés en
fait toutes les rivières qui draine les
flancs de la montagne pelée
donc côté caraïbes comme côté atlantique
peuvent potentiellement générer ce type
de phénomène donc je pense que toutes
les communes devraient peut-être toutes
les communes riveraines devrait être
vraiment aller coûte qu'il faut rester
vigilant merci beaucoup parce que ça
fâche pour cette précision